[Aplausos]
viví durante un mes en la antártida en
una base militar ecuatoriana he dado dos
vueltas al mundo recorriendo unos 70
países en los 5 continentes
en ecuador he subido al cotopaxi he
recorrido europa jalando de do australia
en furgoneta como veis me gusta la
aventura y de eso se venía hablar de por
qué hay que vivir aventuras no sé si lo
saben pero una de las mayores aventuras
náuticas del planeta tierra comienza
aquí en ecuador os voy a contar el viaje
que hice en un pequeño velero de 10
metros desde las islas galápagos hasta
la polinesia francesa se trata de un
viaje de 5 mil 500 kilómetros impulsado
únicamente por el viento cada año
únicamente unas 300 embarcaciones
realizan este viaje porque es muy
peligroso
además voy a decir una cosa lo hice sin
tener un barco sin tener conocimientos
náuticos y con un presupuesto mochilero
porque la gente se piensa que para
viajar hace falta mucha plata y no es
verdad
muchas veces se gasta más plata en quito
que saliendo fuera
bueno y me dirán por qué hice este viaje
pues porque quería vivir una experiencia
única que me llegara a lugares
increíbles que me dejaron una huella en
el alma indeleble también te voy a decir
una cosa había leído sobre la polinesia
un grupo de islas en medio de la nada
habitada por unos grupos de antiguos
guerreros famosos por sus bailes por sus
danzas que practicaban el canibalismo
hasta hace tan solo 100 años el lugar
que eligió paul gaugin el pintor para
desaparecer del mundo está en su tumba
me dije en voz alta miguel no voy a
parar hasta poner una flor en su tumba
también a veces una cosa así a 100 corto
lleva ya un tiempo saliendo con mí con
mi novia claudia claudia y la idea de
casarnos estaba ya sobrevolando sobre mi
cabeza como me dice mi amiga eva antes
de dar un paso de estas características
hay que hacer dos cosas 1 irte a la
piscina juntos obvio
2 hacer un viaje a un lugar recóndito
exótico para desnudarte para ver para
conocer a la persona fuera de su zona de
confort
muy bien miguelángel todo muy bonito
pero ahora como hacemos este viaje como
le das forma a tu locura empecé a buscar
por internet páginas web blogs no había
nada nada
pero en el fondo para mí era una buena
noticia las verdaderas aventuras parten
hacia lo desconocido luego de mirar
mucha y mucha información encontré una
página web que se llamaba fight club
encuentra la tripulación es una página
que pone en contacto propietarios de
barcos con gente que quiere tener una
experiencia náutica que quiere ir en un
barco lo que ocurre que hay decenas de
miles de barcos por todo el mundo los
capitanes siempre necesitan ayuda hay
que limpiar hay que cocinar hay que
hacer las guardias y claro pues una
suerte de trueque no ellos te llevan
gratis y tú les ayudas luego de mucho
buscar encontrar un alemán que se llama
reinhart estaba en panamá y se dirigía a
la polinesia francesa iba a parar en las
islas galápagos era perfecto para mí en
un tipo de unos 50 años el típico alemán
rubio ojos azules muy serio viajaba con
otra chica alemana de su misma edad
total los cuatro quedamos en las
galápagos en la isla isabela no lo
olvidaré nunca
bueno antes de partir llamé a mi madre
porque cualquier aventurero que se
precie sabe que lo más importante que
hay que hacer antes de partir a una gran
aventura es llamar a tus padres y
decirle que todo está bajo control a
pesar de que nada está bajo control te
va a ser con un man que no conoces a
atravesar el pacífico en un bote de
plástico al que la llame leal y bueno y
zarpamos un 26 de abril la verdad que la
sanidad fue increíble había gaviotas
tortugas por ahí flotando delfines eso
parecía buscando a nemo no ya sí
vamos para allá pero claro el segundo
día todo cambió de repente la nada el
mayor desierto de agua del planeta
5 mil 500 kilómetros
tranquila me voy a leer un libro un
libro un par de horas pim pam pim pam
vuelves a ver cinco mil 492
película de la película no se quebró
claro vas a una media de unos 56
kilómetros por hora imaginaros 5 mil 500
kilómetros a esa velocidad película a la
película no sé qué devuelves cinco mil
aparte claro no hay marcha atrás los
barcos veleros van con las corrientes y
las corrientes y vamos por el inferior
sur que van de este oeste teníamos que
salir sí o sí por la polinesia francesa
bueno estamos en ese contexto llegó el
quinto día sexto día y el viento
con el motor no hay motor los barcos de
vela llevan gasolina para unos 400 500
litros que te sirven para cinco o seis
días para emergencias
pero es todo insuficiente para una
travesía de estas características las
que no habían no había nada de viento un
día sin viento dos miras en el tablón de
de mando se pone quedan 47 días yo voy a
morir voy a morir 47 días
este juego es pasó un día dos y bueno lo
que para mí había sido un sueño se
empezó a transformar en una pesadilla
una pesadilla que yo mismo había
construido
decía claudia
el rojo no está y está por dentro de f
en ese contexto en esa locura toque
fondo la verdad tuve ataque de ansiedad
de repente empecé a darme golpes contra
las paredes no podía respirar me
arrepentía todo el rato de lo que había
hecho toqué fondo la verdad tuve un par
de días malos en ese momento en ese
contexto adverso claudia que había
dejado su trabajo y lo había dejado todo
para seguir este don quijote loco fue la
que me dio calma la que me insufló paz
armonía y esperanza en ese contexto tan
complicado tocando fondo se me apareció
jesús
si se me parece que eso no lo voy a
contar no estaba ahí laborda leyendo
como siempre un poco y al capitán miguel
camps camps voy para allá en el radar
aparece un punto pip pip pip pip miro
rosita un atunero español justo en medio
la nada que me parece un barco español
le llamo a la hora llamando llamando a
rossi está llamando a rossi está al otro
lado me salió un señor con una voz muy
muy profunda si quien es claro no
miguelangel que pasa por aquí te he
visto
luego tengo nada que hacer
había un chaval gay se trataba de un
capitán vasco que son los más aguerridos
los más duros de toda españa llevaba
toda su vida navegando se iba a jubilar
ya hablamos un rato le dijo que tenía
una hija de unos 17 años que era
periodista de una cosa yo ni loco me
metía en esa [ __ ] de barquito de
plástico estáis loco ese momento me
empecé a dar cuenta de la gran aventura
en la que estaba inmerso no hablábamos
un rato y me dijo bueno tengo que dejar
y me dijo te puedo ayudar en algo
se puede llegar gasolina está todo bien
justo cuando se va a ir
me acordé de una cosa dije si pudiera
pedir un deseo un solo deseo sería
hablar con mi madre decirle que estamos
bien porque estamos súper retrasados
el barco no tenía la capacidad
tecnológica para hacer ningún tipo de
llamada el suyo sí dije mira por favor
te quiero pedir una cosa me gustaría
enviar un mensaje de un mail a mi madre
a la madre de claudia decirle que
estamos bien solo es ahora un problema
chaval ningún problema para que le diga
el mensaje le di la dirección a dios
justo cuando se iba le dije si se
perdona es una cosa que no me has dicho
cómo te llamas y me dijo un solemne y
rotundo jesús
[Aplausos]
en la aventura pasada esta vez es que
cuando menos te esperan aparecen
personas me dio la nada nunca mejor
dicho y te dejan una huella imborrable
no nunca hubiese vuelto a ver a jesús
pero siempre lo recordaréis bueno aunque
esté de jesús un saludo
el caso que el viento volvió el viento
volvió seguimos avanzando
en ese momento a sentirse mal llevamos
como 15 días de travesías invernado
repito no hay un árbol no hay un teatro
sucre no hay no hay nada nada la gran
nada aparte a no tener ningún referente
espacio-temporal tiempo parece que se
diluye como los relojes de salvador dalí
icloud ya se empezó a asentar más lo
vomitaba todo sólo quería acabar quería
volver y ahí vio como que tome la posta
y ahora que me encargaba de cuidarla
darle ánimos y de cocinar bueno yo era
el cocinero del barco bueno la verdad
que fuimos avanzando los días eran muy
parecidos a los otros no pues leíamos
todo dormíamos mucho uno como que
hibernan para que pase el tiempo rápido
pero también pasaban cosas de repente un
día apareció un cachalote con su cría
otro día aparecieron manadas de delfines
también aparecían ballenas
buscábamos altura es muy grande luego
nos comíamos estaba bien algo que más me
gustaba era las guardias siempre los
barcos tiene que ver alguien en la zona
de mando
para el tema del rumbo el tema de las
velas tema que no haya ninguna
emergencia yo por ejemplo mis guardias
eran de 3 a 6 de la tarde y de 3 a 6 de
la mañana la que más me gustaba era la
de la madrugada imaginaros ahí en medio
de la nada así con mi timón filmaba un
poco así como bien con el rugido de las
olas
todo mundo durmiendo no en el momento
muy muy impactante con el cielo con unas
estrellas una 'vía láctea' que parecía
que casi que la podías tocar unos
momentos muy sagrados no la verdad y
bueno estaba yo ahí solo sintiéndome muy
pequeño pero a la vez también muy grande
una noche de madrugada estaba durmiendo
y me llama al camarote para que
cualquier miguel río ya verás problema
me llama suba arriba la borda estamos en
medio de una terrible tormenta terrible
el barco estaba dando vueltas y me dice
capitán hay que subir arriba el mástil y
bajar las velas porque claro si no se
bajan se pueden estropear
una vez ahí a las dos de la mañana
poniendo en un arnés subiéndome al
mástil así es el barquito así a dos
metros de altura
aesco la lluvia y el viento golpeando me
la cara y tú diciendo que he hecho yo
para merecer mixto echó encima de
acuérdate de tu madre que decía la
vecino que te dije que no fuera
estudiante compra el boleto no vayas no
vayas y tú hay pegas o un grito ahí
hacer lo que tienes que hacer y punto y
te sientes más vivo que nunca porque
también cuando en el viaje en la
aventura se griegas muchas veces una su
extraña sustancia en el cerebro que te
hace verlo todo mejor sentirlo todo
mejor palparlo todo mejor
toma que los 23 días repito 23 días y 23
noches se comenzó a vislumbrar una leve
mota negra en el horizonte era la isla
de bagua yo comencé a correr de un lado
para otro como un primate me abracé a
claudia los dos alemanes presos y fieles
a su condición de autora está viendo un
libro o zona es
yo no podía nos fuimos acercando poco a
poco y de repente empecé a ver la costa
era una maravilla era de color negra de
piedra volcánica todo muy verde
exuberante cuando nos acercamos y nunca
lo olvidaré el olor a tierra luego de 23
días ay me di cuenta porque nos llaman
terrícolas os juro que se me revolvió el
alma
en la tierra no me lo podía creer
no lo imaginé si os digo que apareció un
arcoiris y volvieron delfines manadas
delfines
maravilla llegamos al puerto lo primero
que hice bueno nada más bajar al suelo
por supuesto había mantarrayas en el
puerto eso era mucho mejor de lo que me
imaginaba efectivamente la gente iba a
tatuada de arriba a abajo e iban con
coronas de flores era una maravilla de
una hospitalidad que jamás he visto
también había mantarrayas saltando en el
puerto había cascadas era espectacular
lo primero que hice fue llamar a mis
padres obvio y les dije que bueno que
habíamos llegado hubo risas hubo
lágrimas hemos podéis imaginar me
dijeron que mi abuelita de 92 años había
fallecido en el trayecto y bueno lo que
hice fue [ __ ] unas flores que las de
polinesia son espectaculares y me fui al
cementerio de atún a que es donde está
la tumba de paul gaugin y ahí le puse
unas flores a paul a paul gaugin y
también me pude despedir de mi abuelita
pero los peces que ahí terminó el viaje
no ahí comenzó otro otro maravilloso ahí
conocimos a helle un capitán noruego con
pintas de
y los llevo durante un mes y medio a
recorrer la polinesia francesa hicimos
algunos amigos maravillosos con los que
compartíamos fiestas de disfraces
hacíamos nos íbamos a bucear íbamos a
investigar las islas que visitábamos ha
sido uno de los mejores viajes que he
hecho en mi vida sin lugar a dudas el
esfuerzo valió la pena
una noche de luna llena en la isla de
morea al frente de tahití un lugar
maravilloso en una playa de aguas
prístinas
con una botella de vino francés y un
anillo de perla negra le pedí matrimonio
a mi esposa claudia creo que está por
ahí espero que esté por ahí después ahí
el anillo
[Aplausos]
para mí el viaje y la aventura es una
verdadera escuela de vida me ha enseñado
a enfrentarme a mis miedos a domesticar
los anularlos me ha enseñado a salir de
mi zona de confort
yo tenía un trabajo estable aquí en
quito y mi esposa también y la gente me
decía no no te vayas que nunca vas a
encontrar trabajo
ya verás lo vas a perder todo no no te
vayas y la mentira a la vuelta al cabo
de un mes encontré trabajo después
también yo trabaja en un periódico y me
volvieron a contratar en el mismo
periódico mi amigo luís que es un gran
tipo es cierto que al cabo de al año
siguiente me volvía a ir para implantar
tida pero bueno pero eso es otra eso es
otra historia
el viaje también te enseña a confiar hay
que confiar mucho a la gente como veis
yo viajando me da cuenta de que no hay
desconocidos solo hay amigos que todavía
no conoces también el viaje te hace
sentir que eres dueño de tu propio
destino no como decía hunter thompson
que es un escritor y periodista al que
yo admiro profundamente la vida no
debería ser un camino hacia la tumba
para llegar con un cuerpo bonito y bien
cuidado al revés hay que llegar
derrapando en una nube de polvo
desgastado destrozado para gritar puja
vaya a viajecito gracias
[Aplausos]